[Music]
foreign
at the end of the day
you will never grow out of comfort
that's right and and I did not
um
uh I did not learn the things that I've
learned out of comfort it was hard and
um a lot of people don't know my story
where it really was born
um
was I failed as a leader and uh and I
had done well you know up to you know
here I am I'm this young kid I joined
the SEAL Teams smart enough
and I guess talented enough in the SEAL
Teams to Excel and stand out a little
bit where I could and got selected for a
leader but oftentimes what happens with
a lot of us who Excel When We're Young
especially young men it doesn't happen
as much in young women but I see it
often in young men and I started to get
a little ego started to think I was the
man the danger of success yeah and uh
and really started to think you know I
was better than other people and
um and and success built on top of
success can feed this
and that's what happened to me and I
came back as a young brand new seal
officer thinking man I was God's gift to
leadership and um and oftentimes when
you achieve a level of success then we
start to sit back on our Laurels like
hey man I'm I'm here I've achieved it
you know do as I say not as I do because
I'm already here
and uh
I started making mistakes as a young
leader the world had changed 9 11 had
happened between the time that I got
commissioned between the time that I
started school and became an officer our
tactics changed because we had gone to
war both in Iraq and Afghanistan so a
lot of the older tactics I had learned
growing up weren't the same as what our
guys were running with now
and all of those things were
creating issues for me as a leader and
instead of adapting and humbling myself
and being like hey man to the young guys
around me who now had more experience
than me which my ego wouldn't
acknowledge that I was like hey man I've
been in longer than you I'm a leader
like you know I'm not going to ask you
how to do things which is such a
[__] idea
um you know there are people out there
who believe and I did I guess wrongly
that leaders have to know everything
that is unequivocally not true leaders
aren't going to know everything you're
not going to be great at everything
that's why you surround yourself with
great people but I was
insecure and was unwilling to say to
these young guys hey man I don't know
how to do that could you help me
um so then I went down the road that so
many of us go down when we're struggling
and we know we're [__] up uh I turned
out yeah and uh so and I became
um we would go out at night and I would
you know pour myself into a bottle and
became known as a drunk so we deployed
to Afghanistan in 2005
and in September I made a bad call on a
mission and uh and that was the straw
that broke the camel's back because when
I
um
I had gone down into a valley to try and
support our guys below I took my machine
gunner and dude it is a miracle we did
not the valley was riddled with Taliban
our guys had gotten into a big gun fight
we'd already called in some uh you know
air missions
and I tried to go down and support
um troops that were on the ground some
of our other teammates and some other
some Afghan guys who were down below and
it was just a bad call I won't get into
all the details all of that's written in
my book to try to but um it was a bad
call and it prevented the air support
from coming in for a period of time and
and knock on wood no one was killed or
injured because of that decision but my
professional reputation was killed I got
it by the time I got out to the other
side of the valley we had climbed back
out uh man guys wanted my head on a
block
and uh and they sent me back to
headquarters in Bagram we were operating
down in southern Afghanistan and I
basically went and stood in front of my
commanding officer and was told hey man
like
we're questioning everything about you
we're questioning your leadership we're
questioning your Tactical decision
making we're questioning your your
questioning you being a seal and uh and
there were guys who were bringing that
up hey we should kick him out we should
take his Trident The Shield emblem and
kick him out and uh
and I remember the CEO said hey go back
the commanding officer said go back to
your room I'll let you know my decision
in the morning and I went back to my
room and
um
one I couldn't understand how I gotten
to this point
um which is and I was blaming everybody
else
I was I was a victim hey man I did
things right look at me I went down in
the valley to help people and when that
was just a lie we have a tendency to lie
to ourselves in the victim mindset
because we want to blame everybody
around us and I
um
had not opened the door yet to how did
you get here well bro it was you but I
wasn't there yet
and uh
and I convinced myself as many of us do
when we hit rock bottom that
one it's everybody else's fault and two
there's no way it can be fixed it's too
late it's too late to be fixed you know
all of this is too late and
um and I you know have weapons
everywhere there I mean my all my gear
was next to me and I took my pistol out
and I put it in my mouth and I was going
to blow my head off
and um
you know all the lies that we tell
ourselves the world will be better off
without me
um
it's too late you can't fix this problem
it's the end all these different things
and man I I'm so thankful that right as
I got ready to pull the trigger I I
think the big man above kind of punched
me in the back of the head and I looked
up and there was a picture of My Wife
and Kids on the table
and my uh my son would have been
um
six uh my middle daughter would have
been three and my youngest was one
and he he was like what are you doing
what message do you send them
doing this
and uh that's the other lie we tell
ourselves as as ego like uh
like we have to do it on our own like I
got to figure out this problem on my own
uh and especially in the military and
Special Operations fire law enforcement
Community I talk about this frequently I
don't get it because I've seen it happen
so many times now
um we we work in a career where we
depend on somebody else police officers
have Partners firefighters you will
never go into a building by yourself
seals and Special Operations we don't do
one room clearances yet when we're
struggling mentally we try and fix it on
our own which often Cycles down so I
went and found the chaplain
and I said hey I'm I'm hurting I'm
struggling I said tomorrow they're going
to take my Trident my world is over it's
the end and uh man he changed my mindset
he said hey
I don't know what's going to happen
tomorrow he said but you know no matter
what in this life we have the end
moments and and out of every the end
moment there becomes a new beginning
and he said you shape that new beginning
he said they may take your Trident
tomorrow
or they may not he said no matter what
it's a new beginning he said no matter
what you have got to figure out what
that path is and it's up to you to how
you're gonna to do that
and he was right and the next day they
didn't take my Trident and uh and I'd
love to say that immediately it kind of
flipped this switch but it actually took
several months they ended up sending me
to U.S Army Ranger school as part of my
punishment uh and it was there at Ranger
school that I finally started to grow up
and peel that onion back and go hey bro
guess what everything that happened to
you
it was you it was all your decision
making it was me and selfish it wasn't
setting the example it wasn't creating
structure and discipline in your life it
wasn't being positive it was it was
self-medicating and hiding from your
problems instead of addressing them
and and and it was at Ranger school that
I finally grew up and that became the
the base of everything that I teach on
now every
um
everything grew out of that to be a
better leader to be a better Warrior
um and later those same principles now
apply
um but that is the hardest
that's the hardest Journey I've ever
walked and because there are a lot of
people that are like oh man you got
wounded you know holy smokes you know
shot in the face and 40 surgeries and
um
it wasn't I'll be honest uh that Journey
from that chair with a gun in my mouth
to to two and a half years later
building back my credibility and the
respect of my teammates because to this
day they're still I'm sure some seals
out there that they don't know me they
only know the guy that of Rambo red was
my nickname Rambo red went down in the
valley you know like an [__] risked
his guys lives and they're like you know
[__] that guy and that's fine in this
life you're always going to have haters
people that don't know you they don't
really know your backstory and they
never took the time to learn it but the
guys who I got to be around and who
finally saw this guy's changed and I
hear it a lot now I run into guys that I
haven't seen in years and they're like
you're not the same guy I knew when you
were younger I'm like I am not man
um but
that's why we have to embrace this don't
discomfort that's why you got to get out
of this victim mindset because you'll
never grow if all you ever do is sit
there and you're a victim and blame
everybody else and that opportunity just
comes crashing in with that crisis
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody it's John
Bam Bam the dog uh first on behalf of
both of us and everybody from the real
ones team I just want to sincerely thank
you guys for for tuning in the folks
that I bring on the show they're family
to me and uh being able to tell their
stories and bringing you into their
world is something I'm I'm just super
proud of and again grateful that you
guys tune in we've decided we want to
take things just a step further it's a
patreon community and basically what
that means is if you become a part of
this community look I already board Bam
Bam if you want to become a part of this
community you're going to be able to
hear episodes early and all that ad free
and all that good stuff but there's all
this behind the scenes footage all this
stuff that we've shot that really brings
you into the folks that we've had on the
show really brings you into their world
live chats with me and the folks that I
bring on the show to talk about their
world talk about the issues that they're
dealing with but their triumphs and
their tragedies just go to patreon slash
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
idea was something about building
bridges and and bringing people together
and bringing folks that often don't get
the mic and giving the mic to them so
the fact that you guys tuned in means
the world anyways again thank you be
good to each other out there rock and
roll
I'm gonna get a workout in a little bit
with my man Eric Linden stunt
coordinator from The Punisher he's
coming all the way up because we're
about to get after it and when that's
done he asked me in the car are you
gonna have my shake ready and I know
what that means am I gonna have my son
Warrior Shake they've got the active
protein but they also have this collagen
protein which is amazing they also have
the warrior blend which is a little bit
lighter if you're trying to cut and uh I
believe in it I believe in that some
Warrior stuff go to
www.sunwarrior.com
real ones
[Music]